super la dernière a aimé la polémique et
compris quand ses traits adversaire yale
mais ce soir ce que j'entends nous
plonge dans un roman dans une tristesse
assez profonde mois là où je suis né là
où j'ai vécu quand j'étais enfant il y
avait pas la laïcité y avait pas la
république c'était un système
communautaire où les gens vous avez gros
comme ça j'avais vécu jean chine et au
chili
je sortais pas un pays laïc et je suis
j'ai ensuite vécu en amérique du nord au
canada
quand j'arrivais en france j'ai
découvert la laïcité je savais même pas
ce que c'était j'ai commencéà m'éduquer
là dessus l'idée qu' il y avait une
sphère intime celle de la foi est une
sphère politique et là je suis mais
atterré mais vraiment profondément
atterré d'entendre depuis une semaine
des hommes politiques des responsables
politiques qui rendent allègrement dans
une discussion concernant le dogme
religieux a décidé qu est ce qui est une
bonne application de la religion qu'est
le propre comportement religieux est
possible ou pas possible qui est
français ou ne l'est pas parce que c'est
quand même ça que je viens d'entendre
sur caen tandis que voilées sont pas
françaises mais mais vous pensez c'est
fondamental et vous n'avez pas le droit
et font de ce si vous respectez la
république française si vous respectez
la laïcité
vous devez comprendre que vous devez
rester à votre plane en étant chez lui
vous respectez un mélange liquide et les
françaises ont l'air comme ça l'arrêté
bien vous la république française de la
mode c'est pas votre parti s'est pas
exprimée ministre qui décide qui est
français donc ça c'est la française
laisse qui d'ici dix ans vous allez me
contredire sur la définition la laïcité
la laïcité c'est pas la séparation
justement justement
en train de déplacer la démonstration de
la france par une religion au nom de la
laïcité est très bon vous êtes
exactement si vous vous êtes entré dans
une nouvelle phase de votre discours
angers vous dire c'est important non ça
s'appelle la persécution dans le jeu et
c'est pour ça redémarre inventé la
laïcité dans dit oui il ya eu huit
siècles de guerre larvée entre
catholiques justement comment vous êtes
encore une acquisition géante où vous
allez vous depuis l'opposition d'aller
vous qui en tant qu'élu en train de
décider qui sont les bons français qui
sont les pompes au web français y
fassent a été la même chose quand les
quatre et cinq jeux les frères ou les
armes elles vous juste vrai nous refusez
ça monsieur missia vous n'allez pas voir
les jaloux répondre calmement je vais
juste vous répondre calmement nos
principes sont plus forts que vous m ou
n'a réussi à la guerre civile je vous le
dis mais des voulait bien en crâne
d'accord je te calmer parce que nous les
hommes qu amour nous ne sommes qu'à
moins magnifique takeda ryu voilà à la
grèce raquel garrido à l'avez compris
c'est bon si opéra cas garrido à la
démarrer son intervention alors il était
en président de république à la fille
elle était en floride alors jeune et
amour tout vous de répondre calmement
oui je n'ai pas ce que tu entre autisme
c'est ça messier messier a le
patriotisme c'est où ça s'annonçait
comme son égal c'est pas une surprise
que c'est le patriotisme
alors non non non vous traitez votre
courage politique et les listes
internationales
je vais tous les matches que vous diriez
vous dire c'est alors comme vous n'avez
pas répondu